hello and welcome everyone to yet
another
tech enthusiastic video from simply
learn today
we will learn about collections in java
but before we begin
please be kind enough to get subscribed
to our youtube channel and hit the bell
icon
so that you can stay updated about the
trending technologies in the current
industry
also if you're looking for online
training and certification
programs on the latest technologies like
data science
machine learning and artificial
intelligence or
to master the cutting-edge programming
languages like java
python chap etc then please visit the
simply learn official website
to enroll master and get certified now
without much to do let us dive into our
session
we will start off with the agenda first
we will learn the basic definition of
a java collection followed by that we
will understand
the meaning of java collection framework
after that
we will come across the java collection
hierarchy after we learn the java
collections interface
we will have a briefing about the java
collection interface
methods then up next we will be in the
java collection classes
next we will enter the java collections
apis and finally
we will wind up the session by learning
the benefits of
java collections i hope i made myself
clear with the agenda
now let's quickly dive into our first
topic what exactly is
a java collection a java collection can
be generally defined as a collective
unit of objects
in the form of a group for example a
group of numbers of integer data type
etc moving forward we enter into our
next topic
where we face the java collections
framework
this will help us understand java
collections in a little more detailed
way
a java collection framework represents a
unified architecture
for storing and manipulating a group of
objects its architecture includes the
following
an interface a class and the java
collections
api to understand these in a much better
way
we shall now go through the java
collections hierarchy
the utility package java.util contains
all the classes and interfaces
that are required by a collection
framework the collection framework
contains
an interface named as an iterable
interface
which provides the iterator to iterate
through all the collections
this interface can be extended by the
main collection interface
which acts as the root for the
collection framework
all the collections extend this
collection interface thereby extending
the properties of the iterator
and the methods of this interface the
following figure illustrates the
hierarchy of collection framework
out of the complexities we have the
interface
and the classes as the major part of the
collections
now let us understand each one of them
at one step at a time
as you can see on the screen we have the
iterable class which is
implemented by the collection class and
this particular collection class is
further implemented by list queue and
set
and moving ahead we have the following
classes
which have implemented the list queue
and set classes
in the list we have array list linked
list vector stack and
on the other hand on the queue we have
priority queue
dq and array dq and finally on the set
we have the hash set lint hash set
sorted set reset etc now moving further
we will enter our first java collection
which is none other than the interface
so the first one is an interface an
interface can have
methods and variables but the methods
declared in an interface are by default
abstract that is only the method
signature is available
not the body interfaces specify
what a class must do and not how it must
do
it is a blueprint of a class now a java
collection
is a foundation to the java collections
framework
note that all the collection interfaces
are
generic for example public interface
collection
is the syntax for the generics and when
we declare the collection
we should use it to specify the type of
object
which it can contain it helps in
reducing runtime errors by type checking
the objects
at compile time to keep the number of
core collections interface manageable
the java platform doesn't provide
separate interfaces for each variant
of each collection type if an
unsupported operation is invoked
a collection implementation throws an
unsupported operation exception
now under the collection interface we
have many interfaces
that we should use for data manipulation
a few of the major ones are set
interface
list interface dq interface q interface
map interface sorted set interface
sorted map interface no worry those are
a lot of interfaces but we will discuss
each one of them in a detailed way along
with a practical example
for a better understanding so the first
one in the docket is the set
interface a set is a collection that
cannot contain
any duplicate elements this interface
model
is the mathematical set abstraction and
is used to represent sets such as a deck
of cards
the java platform contains three general
purpose
set implementations the hash set
tree set and linked hash set
the set interface does not allow random
access to an element
in the collection you can use an
iterator for each loop to traverse
elements of
a set now for a better understanding let
us go through a practical example
i have prepared a code document for all
the programs that i am going to explain
to just save time you can always have
access to it all you need to do is just
ask for it in the comment section below
so you can see on my screen
we have an example for set interface
in this particular example we are going
to store the elements 21 23
43 53 22 and 65
so let's try to execute this program and
see the output
so you can see the elements stored in
the set interface are 65 21 53
22 and 23 43 so the sorted set is here
which is the 21 22 23 43 53 and 65
and the first element being 21 and the
last element being 65
so this is how the set interface
practically works now let's move ahead
into our next
type of interface which is none other
than the list interface
so what exactly is a list interface the
list interface is an ordered collection
that can contain
duplicate elements you can access any
element from its
index the list is more likely an array
with dynamic length
the list is one of the most used
collection types an
array list and linked list are the
implementation classes
of the list interface the list interface
provides useful methods to add an
element
at a specific index to remove and
replace elements based on the index
and to get a sub list using the index
for a better understanding let's check
out an example
so this particular program is based on
list
interface so we are going to add in
three names
which are david john and stacy into our
list
and also we have a fourth edition which
is stacy again just to check if the
statement is true it says
list interface also allows duplicate
elements unlike the set interface
so let's try to run this program and see
the output
so you can see the program got
successfully executed and the names
david
john and stacy are added into the list
now let's come back to our program and
remove this command
and try to run again and check if the
fourth element which is the duplicate of
the third stacy
will be added into the list or not so as
you can see the program got successfully
executed and the fourth element which is
stacy
the duplication of the first one got
successfully inserted into the list
so this is how the list interface works
now let's move ahead into
our next type of interface which is the
queue interface
so what exactly is a queue interface q
is a collection used to hold
multiple elements prior to processing
besides
basic collection operations a queue
provides
additional insertion extraction and
inspection operations cues typically
but do not necessarily order elements in
the fifo
or first in first out manner
among the exceptions are priority cues
which order elements according to a
supplied comparator
or the elements in natural ordering
whatever the ordering used the head of
the queue is
the element that would be removed by a
call to remove or
pull in a first and first out cue
all new elements are inserted at the
tail of the cube
now for a better understanding let's go
through a practical example
so as you can see the program on my
screen is an example for
queue interface so in this particular
queue we are going to store the names of
fruits apple mango grapes and banana
and apple being the head of the queue
and banana being the tail of the queue
now let's try to execute this program
and see the output so we are also going
to
count the size of the queue which is
four basically in the first
after that we are going to remove the
element grapes
from the queue so the command is q dot
remove the element name
so after that the grapes element has
been removed from our queue we have the
latest size of the queue as
three now after that we are also going
to check if the element
apple is included in the queue or not
so for that statement yes the element
apple is included in the queue and the
result is true
so this is how the queues work and let's
move further
and in the next phase we have the dq
interface
so what exactly is a dq interface
so a linear collection that supports
element insertion
and removal at both the ends is called
as a dq interface the name dq
is short for double ended queue and is
usually pronounced as
dec most dq implementations place no
fixed limits on the number of elements
they may contain but this interface
supports
capacity restricted dqs as well as those
with
no fixed size limit this interface
defines methods to access the elements
at both the ends of the dq methods are
provided to insert
remove and examine the element for a
better understanding
let's check out an example so you can
see on my screen we have a program for
dq interface
so here we are going to add in some
elements into our dq and then
also try to remove the first element and
print the updated dq
now let's try to execute this program
and see the output
so as you can see the program got
successfully executed and the elements
which we try to push into the dq are
52 10 and 21 52 is being the first
element
and the 21 is being the last element so
we try to remove the first
element which is the 52 so
after that the updated dq is having two
elements which are ten
and twenty one so this is how the queues
work
now let's move ahead and learn our next
type of interface
which is the map interface so what
exactly is a map interface
a java map is an object that maps keys
along with its values a map cannot
contain duplicate keys
each key can map to at most
one value the java platform contains
three general purpose map
implementations
which are the hash map tree map and
linked hash map the basic operations of
a map
are contains key contains value
size and is empty for a better
understanding
let us check out an example so this
particular
example on my screen is an example for
map interface here we are going to add
three elements and map them as one as
cricket
two as hockey and three as archery
now let us execute this program and see
the output
so you can see the program got
successfully executed and the elements
are
mapped with their keys and the element
cricket is mapped with the
key one and similarly hockey with k2 and
r3 with k3 so this is how the
map interfaces work now let's move
further
into our next type of interface which is
the sorted set interface
so what exactly is a sorted set
interface
so a sorted set is a set that
maintains its elements in ascending
order
several additional operations are
provided to take advantage of the
ordering
sorted sets are usually used for
naturally ordered sets such as word list
and membership roles for a better
understanding
let's check out an example based on
sorted set
interface so you can see
the program on my screen is an example
for sorted set interface
so here we are going to add in bob sean
and jennifer into our set and we are
going to
print the same let's try to execute this
program and see the output
so you can see the program would
successfully executed
and we have our elements printed in the
sorted set
and you can see the names are been
arranged in the form of ascending order
according to the alphabets which have
started
in the first position so this is exactly
how the sort
set interface works so the last one in
the interfaces is the sorted map
interface
a map that maintains its mapping in an
ascendant key order
this is the map analog of sorted set
the certain maps are used for naturally
audit collections of
key value pairs such as dictionaries and
telephone directories now for a better
understanding let's check out an
example based on map interface or sorted
map interface
so you can see the program on my screen
is an example for
sorted map interface so here we're going
to
add in the elements john molly aaron and
daisy into the map interface now
along with the names we also have their
aggregates which is
76.5 for john 87.3 for molly
and 78.2 for aaron and for
daisy we have 73.4 now finally we're
going to fetch
the data of molly which is the aggregate
of molly now let's try to execute this
program and see the output
so you can see the program got
successfully executed and knowledge
aggregate is 87.3
so this is how the map interfaces work
now let's move ahead into our
next topic which is the java collection
classes so now that we have finished the
java collection interfaces
let us have a quick understanding of
java interface
methods so the first method is the add
method
the add method is used to add an object
to the collection
and next is the easend method
this method returns to true if the
collection contains
no elements followed by that we have the
clear method
and this method is used to remove all
the elements from the collection
followed by that we have the remove
method this method is used to remove the
given object from the collection
if there are duplicate values then this
method removes the first occurrence of
the object
next to the remove method we have the
size method
so the size method is used to return the
number of elements in the collection
so after the size method we have the
stream method
the stream method is used to return a
sequential stream
with this collection as its source so
the next method we have is
the two array method so the two array
method is used to return
an array containing all the elements in
this collection
followed by that we have the hashcode
method
this method is used to return the hash
code value for this collection
next the equals method the equals method
is used to compare the specified object
with the remaining elements in the
collection
followed by that we have the iterator
method so the iterator method
is used as an iterator over the elements
of the particular collection
and finally we have the contains method
so the contains method returns true if a
specified element
is existing in the collection and false
if it is not present
so with this we finish the collection
interface and
collection interface methods now we will
move ahead into our next topic which is
none other than
the java collection classes so what
exactly is a class
a class is a user-defined blueprint or
prototype
from which objects are created it
represents a set of properties or
methods that are common to all the
objects of
one type now we'll start up with the
first one which is the hash
set class so the java hash set is the
basic implementation of the set
interface
that is backed up by the hashmap it
makes no guarantee
for the iteration order of the set and
permits
null elements as well so this class
offers
constant time performance for basic
operations such as
add remove contains and size assuming
the hash function
disperses the elements properly among
the buckets
we can set the initial capacity and load
factor for this collection
the load factor is a measure of how full
the hashmap is allowed to get before
its capacity is automatically increased
for a better understanding
let's go through an example so on my
screen you can see a program
which is an example for hash set classes
so inside this we are going to store
some names which are the names of the
manufacturers of bikes
along with null values so we have added
in
two null values to just check if it
allows two null values at once
so basically it only should allow one
null value
so let's check out how does it perform
so you can see the program was
successfully executed
and the null value is stored only once
that two in the first location
so this is how the hash set classes
work moving further we will deal with
the next type of class
which is the tree set class so a tree
set class is a navigable set
implementation based on a tree map
the elements are ordered using their
natural ordering
or by a comparator provided at set
creation time
depending on which constructor is being
used this implementation provides
guaranteed log stein cost for the basic
operations such as add remove and
contains note that the ordering
maintained by a set
whether or not an explicit comparator is
provided
must be consistent with equals if it is
to correctly implement the set interface
now to understand in a much better way
let us go through an example
now we are going to add in some numbers
into the tree set using the add
method now let's execute this code and
see the output
so you can see the numbers are added
into the tree set
and the numbers are ordered in ascending
order
which is 0 18 88 748
983 845
now let's move further into our next
type of class
which is the arraylist class
so add a list in java is a resizable
array
that is an implementation of list
interface that allows
null elements so in this class we have
three types of arrays which
are one-dimensional arrays
two-dimensional arrays and
three-dimensional arrays
now let's check out the one-dimensional
array
so a one-dimensional array looks
similar to this where we have the array
index
and the element present in the array so
here
our indexes are a0 1 2 3 and 4 and the
elements
which are shown here to understand
one-dimensional arrays in a much better
way let's go through a sample program
so you can see the program written on my
screen is an example for one-dimensional
array and we are going to store the
elements 10
20 and 30 into my array a
so you can see the program has been
successfully executed and the elements
have been added into my one dimensional
array
moving further we will discuss the
two-dimensional arrays
the two-dimensional arrays are
completely similar to one-dimensional
array
but the only difference is the index
numbers
earlier we had index number but now we
have index numbers
now using these index numbers we can
represent the elements
in a matrix form so to understand this
in a much better way
let's go through a sample code so you
can see
this particular program in my screen is
an example for two-dimensional
arrays so here we are going to add in
elements
one two three and four in the matrix
form and we are going to use two for
loops to print that
now let's execute this program and see
the output so you can see
we have the elements 1 2 3 and 4 and
the elements are printed in the matrix
form at the array index location 0 0 we
have 1
0 1 we have 2 and 1 0 we have 3
and 1 1 we have four so this is how the
two dimensional arrays work
and finally let's deal with the third
type of array which is the
multi-dimensional or
three-dimensional array so you can see
the three-dimensional array is
completely similar or
a little bit similar to the
two-dimensional array but the only
difference is
we have a third vector here so next up
we have the linked list
linked list also come under java
collection classes
there are three types of linked lists
which are single linked list
doubly linked list and circular linked
list
now let's check out each one of those so
the first one is the singly linked list
so you can see in a singly linked list
each memory segment is divided into
two parts so the first half of the
memory location is
given for the element and the second
half of the memory location is
dedicated for the address so this
particular address is used to
point to the next element or the next
memory allocation
which stores the second element
similarly the third
so this is how the singly linked list
works so the last memory allocation is
called as
tail and the last address
will not store nothing but null which
indicates the end of the singly linked
list
now to understand singly linked list in
a much better way
let's try to execute a sample program
so you can see the program on my screen
is an example for singly linked list
now we are going to add in the elements
one two three and four
in the form of a singly linked list now
let's try to execute this program and
see the output
so you can see the program got
successfully executed and the elements
are one
two three and four now let's move
further and try to learn the next type
of linked list
which is the doubly linked list so the
doubly linked list is completely similar
to that of the singly linked list
but the only difference is we have two
address locations so the first address
location
of the head stores null and the last
address location of the tail
stores null which indicate
the start and end of the doubly linked
list respectively
so here in the second memory location
you have
two addresses so the first address
points to the previous element and the
next address points to the next element
so to understand doubly linked list in a
much better way let's try to execute a
sample program
so as you can see the program on my
screen is
an example for doubly linked list and we
have the node
which has the data and previous address
next address now let's try to execute
this program and see the output
and the elements that we are going to
store in this particular doubly linked
list are 1 2
3 4 and so as you can see the program
got successfully executed and the notes
are one two three and
four and five so this is how the w link
lists work and now let's check out the
third type of
linked list which is the circular linked
list so there are similarities between
the previous linked list
and the circular linked list so the
circular linked list
makes it circular based on the last
address location
so this particular address location
points to the first element
back again so this is how it becomes a
circular linked list
so to understand this in a much better
way let's check out an example for it
so you can see the program
on my screen is an example for circular
linked list
now let's try to execute this and see
the output so you can see we have
successfully included
one two three four five six and seven
and eight into
our circular linked list and they are
printed on the screen
so this is how the circular linked list
work
so moving further we will try to
understand the next type of classes in
java collections which is the hashmap
class
so hash table is based on the
implementation of map interface
this implementation provides all the
optional
map operations and permits null values
and the null key
hash map class is roughly equivalent to
hash table
except that it is unsynchronized and
permits
null this class makes no guarantee for
the order of the map
now for a better understanding let's go
through a sample program
so this particular program on my screen
is an example for
hashmap class so here we are trying to
load the data which is the name of the
manufacturer
and their bike so let's execute this
program and see the output
so you can see the program got
successfully executed and
we have the manufacturer and their mate
bikes
now moving further we will deal with the
next type of
class in java collection which is
the tree map class so the tree map is
based on navigable map
implementation the map is sorted
according to the natural ordering of its
case or by a comparator provided at
map creation time depending on the
constructor
used now let's check out an example for
better understanding
so you can see the program written on my
screen is an example for tree map class
so we have the roll numbers and the
names of students here
now let's try to execute this program
and see the output
so the program got successfully executed
and the result has been printed on the
output console
so we have the roll numbers of the
students and their names
amber james wallet and reynolds along
with their respective ids
so now with this we complete the java
collections classes now we move into our
next topic which is the collection api
algorithms so the first one is sorting
sorting does the job of ascending and
descending numbers based on the
algorithm written by the user
for a simple example we shall consider
the bubble sort algorithm for this one
so you can see on my screen we have an
example for bubble sort algorithm
so we have the elements 289 39 48
6 28 1 2 and 33 which are ordered in
an orderly manner let's try to execute
this program and order them
so you can see array before bubble sort
is 289 38 48
similarly 33 and after the bubble sort
we have the sorted
array which is 1 2 6 28 33 39 48
and 289 so this is how the bubble sort
works
now let's move further and understand
the next type of
api which is the shuffling algorithm
so the shuffling algorithms are designed
to destroy the current arrangements
they are employed on creating randomness
in the list
so for a better understanding let's
check out an example
so you can see the program written on my
screen is an example for
shuffle algorithm so we have an array
which has
the elements completely sorted in
ascending order
which is 10 to 100. now when we run the
shuffle algorithm these elements will be
completely shuffled according to a
random order
now let's try to execute this program
and see the output so you can see the
elements which
were in an ascending order are now
completely in this order
so this is how the shuffling algorithm
works now let's move further
and understand the next type of
algorithm which is the searching
algorithm
searching algorithm is employed to
search an element in the list or array
based on the type of searching mechanism
used now for example
let's use the binary search now you can
see
a program on my screen which is an
example for binary search
so we have the elements 1 2 3 4 and 5 in
our array
now what we are going to do is search
for the element or the key element
2 in our array using the binary search
algorithm
now let's execute this program and see
the output now you can see the program
got successfully executed and the output
says
the element which you're looking for is
found in the index location
one so this is how the binary search
algorithm works
now let's move further and understand
the next type of algorithm
which is the composition algorithm so
the definition says
the frequency and disjoint algorithms
test some aspect of composition
of one or more collections so the
frequency counts the number of times the
specified element occurs in the
specified collection
so the disjoint determines whether two
collections are disjoint
that is whether they contain no element
in common or not
now to understand it in a much better
way let's go through an example
so you can see on my screen there is an
example for composition
now let's run this program and see the
output
so you can see the program was
successfully executed and the elements
are
completely disjoint now moving further
we will enter into our next topic
which is based on the benefits of
java collections so there are various
benefits of java collections out of
those the major benefits are
software or code reusability so the java
collections enable
code reusability to save time followed
by that the ease of designing apis
so the next two ease of designing apis
we have the simplicity in learning and
using apis and finally increased speed
in programming so these were the major
benefits of
java collections so with this we have
come to an end of this session
i hope this was resourceful and if you
have any queries regarding this session
then please feel free to drop them down
in the comment section below
also don't forget to subscribe the
simply learn youtube channel and hit the
bell icon
to stay connected to us and get
important updates
based on the current id this is ravi
signing off
thank you until next time
[Music]
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel
and click here to watch similar videos
to nerd up and get certified
click here